hey guys in this video I want to talk
about vitamin A okay there's some real
interesting about vitamin A it's a fat
soluble vitamin what does that mean you
have water soluble vitamins and you have
fat Seibel vitamins that's how the
vitamins have the ability to travel
through fat to be stored in fat longer
it has the ability to go through cell
walls because the layer around cells are
fat lipid layers or fat layers these
vitamin A that side with vitamins can go
right through the cell where water
soluble vitamins cannot so they can
affect the deep parts of the cell the
DNA the alteration of the DNA and that's
why vitamin D deficiencies can really
affect what your skin turns into okay at
the genetic level so you can have a lot
of little flaking things on your skin
little white little dots on the skin on
the hair follicles you can have little
skin flakes on the scalp you can have
acne different types of acne cystic acne
acne on your back it can create a lot of
problems with your vision as well
because vitamin A is necessary for your
eye so if you can't see at night when
you're driving at night use hard to see
that's a vitamin A deficiency okay also
lubrication of the eye and the mouth and
anything any glandular secretion of like
if you don't have enough of that
lubrication that's about it man a
deficiency also infections sinus
infections ear infections lung
infections all can be triggered by a low
vitamin A level so it has a lot to do
with your immune system so vitamin A
gives support to the eye to the skin to
the immune system to the inner skin to
around your consign your nasal passages
so if you have let's say sleep apnea or
anything that's going on with the inner
skin of your throat that could be
vitamin A deficiency okay
now here's what people don't realize
Vita munay is in cod liver oil thin
liver thin butter
it's an eggs specially the yolk it's in
cheese okay that's the active form that
a minute called retinol now it's true
that kale spinach
carrots sweet potatoes greens also have
vitamin A and they have a lot of vitamin
A but here's what people don't realize
this is a pre vitamin A so anything
vegetable as a pre vitamin it's not an
active form it's not retinol it has to
be converted into an active form that
conversion only takes place at certain
parts of your body and it only certain
percentages so if you're lucky you might
get between 4 to 6 present percent
conversions so if you're consuming a
hundred milligrams let's say that
vitamin A from cow you're only getting 4
to 6 percent of that ok so just because
you're eating kale doesn't mean you're
going to get enough vitamin A especially
if you're not consuming these products
so that's just some interesting
information ok so now here's the next
question what causes a vitamin A
deficiency now it could be you're not
consuming enough of these or maybe
you're not converting these right here
but more likely you probably are
consuming enough vitamin A but the
deficiency comes from the ability to
convert and that has to do with your gut
if your digestive system is damaged or
you have a history of taking antibiotics
we have leaky gut or some type of
digestive issue chances are you can't
convert this so everything's going to
dry out your hair is going to dry out
your skin is going to dry eyes dry so
you'll start manifesting vitamin A
deficiencies the other cause of vitamin
A deficiency is a lack of bile B il e
from the gall bladder why because the
gall bladder helps you break down fats
and breaks down the fat soluble vitamins
so your body can start utilizing them so
if you don't have a gall bladder that
means you probably don't have enough
bile to absorb vitamin A you might have
to take some bile as an as a supplement
ok so let's say you get you have another
you just have a congested liver and the
symptoms of that would be bloating
burping belching right shoulder pain
constipation those are indications that
you don't have enough bile okay it could
be because your stomach is not acid
enough so you have heartburn well that
means that that means you don't have
enough acid
because in order for you to release your
own bile you need a very strong stomach
so it could be that the stomach is not
releasing the bile to help you absorb
vitamin A so again I just want to give
you that background in case you're
taking about a minute it's not working
because you probably can't absorb it all
right so I hope that gave you some data
about vitamin A post your comments below
and I'll see in the next video hey guys
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it please click the share
button below and I will see you in the
next video